what's going on guys this is rob and
while i don't know how well this video
will do
with the series coming out i figured it
was prudent to make a video explaining
the character of she-hulk so she-hulk
also known as jennifer walters first
appeared in savage she-hulk number one
in 1979 and was created by stan lee and
john bessema now here's the thing about
this one of the things that we discussed
in past videos we were doing character
explanations is that more often than not
when marvel was going to introduce a new
character to the comics they usually did
it in an existing comic book series or
in some kind of an anthology series a
really good example is that moon knight
was introduced in the old werewolf by
night comics because they didn't know if
moon knight was going to be a sellable
character so they actually initially
introduced him as a one-off but he
proved to be popular so they gave him
his own solo series at least what passes
for a solo series until he actually got
a self-titled series you usually saw
that when it came to things like marvel
presents marvel premiere marvel two and
one so on and so forth ensemble and or
team up books that serve the purpose of
allowing marvel to get the most bang for
their buck as well as the reader so
marvel could make a story that would
have five stories in it and so even if
one of those stories sucked they still
had four other characters they could
likely make that were marketable and
that people could basically buy with
them giving she-hulk her own solo series
right off the bat this was kind of an
act of desperation by marvel as a result
of the circumstances and what i mean by
that is whether you've looked it up on
your own or something that you've heard
you're most likely correct if you draw
the conclusion that the creation of
she-hulk was based on the success of the
incredible hulk tv series with lou
ferrigno and bill bixby the reason why
this matters is because at that point in
time the incredible hulk tv show as it
was launched was basically licensed and
really the the film and tv rights were
owned by mca universal nowadays it's
owned by nbc university the important
thing here is that because of the way
the licensing rights were worked out if
mca universal had created a she-hulk
before marvel comics did they would have
wholly owned the rights to it whereas if
marvel comics had created she-hulk
before mca universal did marvel comics
would have owned the rights to it and
then mca universal would have had to
license the character from marvel comics
if they wanted to put she-hulk in the in
the tv show and so as a result of that
marvel really believed that it was
inevitable that universal was going to
do that they thought it was only a
matter of time which is something that
happens when it comes to licensing
rights right it's kind of almost sort of
racing yourself to the punch to a degree
but the result of this is that marvel
just launched she-hulk in savage
she-hulk issue number one this allowed
them to lock down the character in its
entirety where there would be no legal
loopholes in the sense that well you
know she-hulk technically appeared in
this other comic over there but it's not
really a she-hulk comment because it
wasn't really her own comic this
definitively locked it down so that's
why or at least seems to be the reason
marvel gave her her own solo series
right off the bat now the funny thing
about this is stan lee wrote the first
issue and then essentially walked away
now a lot of this was because stan lee
was working on the back end with like
the film and tv side and so on and so
forth but this is the reason why the
first issue of savage she-hulk feels
very much like a classic marvel comic
story in the sense that what you had was
a guy named nicholas trask who was a
crime boss living in california that
jennifer walters had crossed paths with
in a couple different ways the first was
because nicholas craft had actually had
her mom killed or killed her mom at a
previous point in time and two jennifer
walters working as a lawyer was actually
building a case against trask using the
help of another gangster that tras could
double crossed and as a result of this
this led to trask sending his guys after
jennifer walters in order to basically
kill her now because bruce banner was
the only person there and as a cousin he
had a matching blood type and could give
her a blood transfusion that's exactly
what happened what ended up resulting
from this is that jennifer walters ended
up absorbing part of the gamma radiation
within bruce banner himself or at least
that was transferred to her through the
transfusion and so jennifer walters
ended up becoming she-hulk now one of
the things to know is that where stan
lee did only write the first issue and
the remaining 24 since it ran up to
issue number 25 the remaining 24 were
written by david kraft the determination
of whether or not this run was a good
run as always is usually left to the
reader there are some people who believe
that david craft's run felt more like
just a series of incredible hulk stories
that just happened to have she hulk in
there instead of bruce banner there are
other people who saw it as the opposite
that it's the most significant run of
she-hulk because it laid the foundation
and groundwork for so many of the things
that we know now but regardless of what
stance you take there are things that
were done in the david craft run that
were stupendously important the first of
these is that the way that david craft
had well crafted his run
no pun intended but the way that he had
built his run was
really first and foremost focusing on
the dichotomy between jennifer walters
and she hook and a lot of this was
designed to reel in female readers at
the time and actually build on the
notion and the nature of
really just second wave feminism as it
existed for a lot of women out there who
were working in these roles like she did
as a lawyer which was largely a boys
club but also having this sort of
untapped inner strength for jennifer
walters that untapped inner strength
manifested in the form of the she-hulk
persona the reason why i use the the
term persona here is that in the initial
stories by david kraft there wasn't
really an ability by jennifer walters to
control herself when she was the
she-hulk she was by all standards of
measurement exactly like bruce banner
the she-hulk persona would manifest
usually in response to some kind of
heightened emotional duress anger more
often than not and then she would sort
of lose herself but over the course of
the comics that began to shift and in
fact the ability of jennifer walters to
maintain her persona even when she was
in the she-hulk form is one of those
elements that actually carried on into
the future of her stories the second
part of this is jennifer walters trying
to find some measure of balance between
her life and becoming a superhero as
well as having just some measure of
normalcy right just the normal jennifer
walters being a lawyer this was very
similar to the way that peter parker was
handled in the spider-man comics albeit
with a little more leeway the idea of
she-hulk leaning into her sexuality
didn't really become a major focal point
for her character until you got to john
burns run but up until that point it was
her just like trying to find romantic
relationships trying to date that sort
of thing trying to find a life for
herself but in a lot of ways david
craft's run still fell into the
traditional superhero story type so he
hadn't quite hit that chris claremont
level of writing where it was more on
the uh kind of interpersonal
relationships soap opera type dynamic as
opposed to like the stan lee's standard
but the thing about this is following
this run because it only ran for about
two years this went into 1982 and there
were there was only really one time when
she-hulk crossed over in another story
and it was a marvel team-up comic beyond
that it was issues just like two through
25 written by david craft the stories
involving nicholas trask and all that
those were all sorted out those were all
rounded up pretty well it was pretty
basic but the reason why this matters is
because during this point in time when
david craft was writing she-hulk
following her introduction jim shooter
was editor-in-chief now those of you
guys who are familiar with my channel or
you're familiar with the history of
marvel comics you know that like the big
thing that jim shooter had during his
time as editor-in-chief and marvel were
the secret war stories and so the whole
idea behind this was that one at least
as far as most of our discussions have
been had when it came to secret wars is
that it was a story that marvel wrote in
order to secure a brand deal with mattel
so they could sell toys and that's true
but the other side of the equation was
that because of the high profile nature
of the story and the fact that you had
such hugely popular characters in that
you had like galactus and you had ultron
you had doctor doom you had all these
different characters that were out there
that what marvel what it also gave them
the ability to do was bring in
characters who otherwise would just
never be noticed by readers in order to
try to raise their profile a little bit
but secret wars at least for she-hulk
was also one of those giant
transitionary stories and so that's the
reason why in the two years that
followed between 1982 when when savage
she-hulk was ended in 1984 when secret
wars was launched you actually saw
marvel shopping her around and so by the
time you got to savage she-hulk issue
number 25 she woke herself and just kind
of become comfortable in the idea of
being in that form and so that was
marvel's way of essentially locking her
down and saying okay this is kind of her
permanent form and it's more the inverse
of what you're used to in the sense that
it's jennifer walters occasionally
becoming she-hulk and now it's she-hulk
occasionally becoming jennifer walters
it was a cool concept that actually
happened for a little while but in
avengers issue number 221 she officially
joined the team she stayed there for a
little while for a couple of years and
she bounced around between a few stories
a few fantastic four comics here and
there albeit not officially joining the
team instead that came at the end of
secret wars that at the end of that
story the desire of marvel was to sort
of reshuffle the team a little bit if
only as an experiment and so at the end
of secret wars ben graham who had
basically been de-powered remained on
battle world for the purpose of just
kind of trying to figure himself out
this opened a spot for someone to
replace him on the fantastic four and
that person was chosen to be she-hulk
now the funny thing about this is that
at that point in time the fantastic four
was being handled by john byrne and what
this meant was that john byrne could
quite literally just craft her character
seemingly any way he wanted to which
would actually prove to be instrumental
because the work that he did on she-hulk
during her time in the fantastic four
would actually become incredibly
important regarding the work that was
done with her character in the
sensational she-hulk run which we'll
talk about here in a few minutes but the
thing about this is that as opposed to
the david craft run and even during her
time in secret wars her time on the
fantastic four was monumental because
what it did is it expanded on her
character in ways that we just hadn't
necessarily considered before but it
also was essentially a paradigm shift
one of the ways in which this was done
was the way that she was depicted
instead of the david craft days where
she was being drawn as really more of
kind of like a hulk type figure where
she looked more muscular and so on
during the avengers run for example she
was drawn to look more slender she
looked more physically attractive the
way that you would expect a beautiful
woman to look another example of this
was that during the avengers run for
example she became a great friend to
hawkeye in the sense that the two of
them had a phenomenal friendship and
arguably a little bit more depending on
how it is that you choose to look at it
but it was one of these things where her
personality as a person was really
starting to shine through because in the
comics it was being depicted that she
was simply just becoming more
comfortable in her own skin another
aspect of this is that it's one thing to
present a character that is attractive
and puts off all the the heirs right and
has all the the trappings of a person
who is strong and confident and so on
it's another one to be able to tell
compelling stories or for them to be
able to live up to the part and so
during the time when she hulk was on the
fantastic four from issues 265 to 300
that john byrne actually crafted a
series of stories that put her in a
position to where she had to essentially
stand on her own two feet without the
other members of the fantastic four and
demonstrate exactly what she was capable
of a great example of this is in
fantastic four issues 283 through 284
when she hulk ended up in the microverse
and ended up basically fighting
alongside queen perla who was the i
guess the queen of mirwood which is one
of the areas within the microverse
itself and fighting alongside her were
able to basically free the microverse
from the control of psychoman now the
reality is that the plot itself and the
story itself was not overly phenomenal
but there were a lot of stories like
that with uh with she-hulk in the
fantastic four comics and that's why
depending on who you talk to some people
will say that she-hulk's time on the
fantastic four was less about her
contributions to the team and was
actually more about building up what she
hulk was actually capable of doing using
the fantastic four because it was the
best place to do it but regardless of
one argument or the other the fact is
that she-hulk's role in marvel became
solidified during the sensational
she-hulk run by john byrne now when i
say john burns run one of the things to
know is that his run was actually fairly
limited in the sense that he wrote
issues one through eight he came back
for issues 31 through 46 skipped 47 then
wrote 48 through 50 and that was
basically it uh one of the things to
understand this is really why his run is
so significant is because it deviated
away from the the nature of she-hulk as
she was originally presented it felt
more rank and file with the version of
she-hulk he had written in fantastic
four and then honestly just became fun
and that was the thing about it because
up to that point in time and this is the
reason why he ended up basically why he
departed the series is because you had
two she-hulk novels or graphic novels
that came out the first one was marvel
graphic novel the sensational she-hulk
number one and that basically set up the
john burns solo series but you also had
one called sensational she-hulk ceremony
issues one and two and that's the one
that basically led to everything popping
off that the first graphic novel
sensational she-hulk number one that was
john burns setting everything up so for
example she hulk was just stuck in her
form she wasn't really able to go back
to jennifer walters there were some
changes that were made later on to where
it was more of a choice than the fact
that she was forced she started
introducing herself as jennifer walters
instead of introducing herself as she
hulk but basically leading in to the
nature of herself as she-hulk as a whole
right just fully becoming that character
the ceremony storyline was a storyline
that actually dealt with her and wyatt
wingfoot their relationship that had
kind of been on-again off-again the two
of them were supposed to get married but
this idea that ultimately it didn't work
out and that she hulk instead of being
this woman that kind of leaned into her
own independence and saying look like i
don't need a guy to fuel hole in this
world the ceremony storyline actually
dealt with this idea that she felt
incomplete because like she couldn't
have a family different things like that
it wasn't so on the nose as saying like
here's a story where she hulk is an
incomplete woman because she's not
living a stepford life but it is one of
those stories where it seemed to just
totally be removed and have a complete
and total misunderstanding of what
she-hulk was supposed to be about in the
eyes of john byrne and so where that
ceremony story was sent to bern to
basically edit it or at least to get
some feel for it to send back some notes
to ensure the graphic novel would fall
in line with his sensational she-hulk
run the opposite happened and in fact
the editor was ignoring the notes that
he'd left and whenever he sent his
scripts in for the sensational she-hulk
run his scripts were actually changed to
match the graphic novel and so he
ultimately ended up leaving where there
was some disagreement there and arguably
at least in his own forum post he was
forced off the title he was basically
fired but that's why he ended up walking
away again he ended up coming back the
reality is that the stories that you saw
with she-hulk that didn't really feature
john burn just didn't quite have that
john burn touch but the funny thing
about this is that the sensational
she-hulk run it's less about like these
massive expansions on her character and
it's less about her just being thrown
into like these impossible situations
instead it was just good old-fashioned
fun it was john byrne having her break
the fourth wall all the time but it was
one of those things where the stories
were just fun it was a blast it was one
of those where you saw like these just
z-less villains beyond zealous villains
being pulled out of nowhere to just like
face off against she-hulk you saw her
face up against titania different things
like that but it was a story that was
not meant to be taken seriously it was
designed to be more entertaining which
is why you would see her say things like
hey guys if you don't buy this comic
they're gonna cancel us right it was
just that kind of stuff and fans loved
it i would go as far as to say that in
terms of just pure enjoyment and kind of
leaving out the overarching character
development based on things that will be
a permanent part of her character in the
future going forward that john burns run
on she-hulk is probably the most
celebrated run on her character but the
fact is that she achieved a level of
popularity during the sensational
she-hulk run that just simply hasn't
been matched and what's so crazy about
that is once that run was ended and she
was taken off of that she-hulk's
popularity never recovered while i take
that back i think that's a bit of an
overstatement i wouldn't say her
popularity never recovered i would say
her ability to hold a solo series never
quite recovered and so that's why
following that story and for a number of
years she hulk's appearances in marvel
comics are just a veritable smorgasbord
of well she was just all over the damn
place i mean she was everywhere right
just in all these different kinds of
comics and in reality as chaotic as that
sounds it's actually the one thing that
saved her to be quite honest right so
she had a bit of a time when she was in
or at least when she was on the
fantastic force team which was basically
franklin richard's own superhero team
she was on that that uh that team for
issues 12 through 18 running up to 1996.
she was in the doc sampson miniseries
she was back in incredible hulk with
issues number 441 going through 442 from
1997 to 1998 she was on heroes for hire
uh she was part of the onslaught saga
for a time the heroes for hire siege of
wondergoer five-part mini-series she was
a part of that i mean she was all over
the place right she was just everywhere
and a lot of this was synonymous with
the fact that marvel just didn't know
what to do with her and as we've always
talked about before in previous videos
it was the mid-1990s comic book bust so
while she-hulk was a recognizable name
she wasn't really a sellable name and
this was partially due to one of these
things where marvel couldn't tell the
difference between the two was she-hulk
a character that just wasn't marketable
because john verne was just the one guy
who could write compelling stories about
her or was she hulk not marketable
because the stories they were putting
her in were just really crappy stories
not only that even marvel themselves
were just throwing everything at the
wall they were literally doing
everything they could to try to make at
least try to tell try to sell something
over fear of going bankrupt but this
seemingly hugely disorganized mess that
was just she-hulk in marvel comics
basically came to a head in 2002 with
avengers issue number 57. now this was
avengers as it was written by jeff johns
and a lot of you guys probably don't
know that jeff johns wrote for marvel
comics before he wrote for dc the funny
thing about it is that world trust i
mean it's okay world leaders disappear
into a black hole it's not really all
that interesting red zone was really
really good that was one of the most one
of the most interesting stories ever in
an avengers comic that explicitly dealt
with the red skull and then following
that you dealt with a story called the
search for she-hulk these were
stupendously important stories for a
variety of reasons one of the most
notable is because it basically set the
stage for jennifer walters to be able to
revert back into her human form and in
fact it was one of these scenarios where
you had a guy by the name of jack of
hearts whose powers directly conflicted
with she-hulk and actually sent her into
a rage once she eventually went back
into her human form then it basically
opened the door for marvel to allow her
to start switching back if they chose to
so this is one of those stories that
jeff johns had written for the purpose
of allowing she-hulk kind of return back
to the status quo for marvel to kind of
find a way to do a little more with her
character now of course jeff johns left
the avengers title not too long after
and while she-hulk did get another solo
series that only ran for about 12 issues
or so towards the end of that run we
ended up going into like avengers
disassemble which of course is one of
the more iconic moments in the she-hulk
mythos when she's manipulated by the
scarlet witch she's sent into like just
this almost out of control world war
hulk-esque persona where she just goes
nuts trashes avengers mansion and then
takes off and so during this time with
dan slott basically writing her solo
series in she-hulk uh this ran for
issues one or at least he wrote issues 1
through 21 and then in turn you had
peter david who took over with issues 22
through 38. now the funny thing about
this is that these these stories could
not have been more different despite the
fact that it was two people writing the
same comic really just the two different
points in time they were starkly
different so dan's slot focused more on
what was in effect the aftermath of like
civil war and all that kind of stuff
this whole idea of there being like
superhuman law her being a lawyer for
superhumans and then in turn at the end
of his run or at least during the peter
david run she was effectively disbarred
for attacking somebody in public even
though they had basically you know was a
lawyer client confidentiality or
whatever it was but she basically
violated her oath as a lawyer this led
to her becoming a bounty hunter during
the peter david run now again it wasn't
really a bad thing and in fact both runs
have their merit neither one of them are
really really terrible um a lot of
people say that the the run of she-hulk
by dan's slot is usually more enjoyable
just because it's a little more
light-hearted but again this is one of
those instances when marvel was just
trying to find a way to make her work
because following the end of peter
david's run and what little crossover
she had in this x-factor comic the
reality is that you saw her disappearing
in a series of whole comic books and
like that was it right i mean you had
some spin-offs that came out of that but
there wasn't a whole lot doing now
charles seoul came out in 2014 to
basically write a 12 issue series for
she hulk but honestly people it that one
again is also very divisive i personally
never really enjoyed it and then of
course you got her in the post civil war
2 landscape focusing on her individual
series and at the moment she's currently
a member of the avengers but the reality
here is that while a lot of the stories
that focused on she-hulk in the 1990s
and the early 2000s focused largely on
her as like the hulk right just the
female version of the hulk going forward
and being a traditional superhero from
really i would argue dan slot's run
going forward more emphasis was put on
her as a lawyer and in fact finding that
middle ground between the two sort of
borrowing from john burns time when she
was on or at least when he was writing
uh the sensational she-hulk story when
you basically had her kind of taking
breaks and being on again off again with
like the avengers team that it was one
of those things where like she had her
own life her own stories basically
dealing with law or legal profession or
being a lawyer or what have you but
while some of these were interesting and
they were really intriguing the reality
here is that since the days of john
byrne's run on sensational she-hulk she
just hasn't quite achieved that level of
popularity and even now on jason aaron's
avengers run the only real story she's
had was world war she-hulk which focused
on her and it was a terrible story so it
seems like a lot of the writing that's
being done with she-hulk at the moment
seems less to do with writers genuinely
understanding her character and crafting
her character in a way that's highly
relatable and really builds on the work
that was done from days gone by and kind
of feels more like a cash grab based on
the fact that like this she-hulk show's
coming into existence which kind of
sucks because if you write a bunch of
half-assed stories about a character
because they're getting a show then
people are going to go read those comics
they're going to realize they're a
half-assed character and they're never
going to buy those comics again so i get
is trying to find a balance between the
greatest reward for the least amount of
work possible but the reality here is
that she-hulk is a character that does
have a lot of potential she is really
really interesting and can be done in a
very interesting way the truth about it
though is that marvel just hasn't really
done that with her character for almost
20 years that following the events of
sensational she-hulk by john byrne she's
just kind of bounced around she's been
on different teams she's had a few
moments here and there like a really
good instance is when she was arrested
by the time variants authority and she
had some cool little moments there but
she never really had an overarching
awesome lengthy significant run it was
just this happened and that happened
like these small little things here and
there but nothing huge and of major
significance that really just changed
the dynamic of her character so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace